hi everyone my name is ridhi welcome uh
two Sigma is excited to be hosting the
New York open statistical programming
Meetup founded by Josh Reich and Drew
Conway this Meetup started in 2009 with
just a handful of people since then it
has grown to over 14 000 members from
around the world the mission is to
spread knowledge of statistical
programming techniques in open source
languages like R python Julia and go and
data science in general I'll now hand it
over to Jared Zander the organizer of
the Meetup Chief data scientist of
Flander analytics and the author of R
for everyone so welcome everybody it's
great to be back in person again
it's been a long time been a long time
coming and black everyone who's here
virtually thank you for attending people
in person we had a few last year and one
in January it's really excited to have
all these people in the room again so
I'm very very excited about that so
thank you all for being here it's a
great great see everybody
so first up long time members know that
the first question I always ask is who
is hiring
so is anyone here hiring
all right let's do a can we have a
second microphone we could pass back and
I'll repeat it for the camera Casey
people can't hear
yeah right right there and can we
confirm that the live stream as audio
Yeah
uh my name is Ed Carlson I work for a
company called tv01 we report uh loan
level information about bonds we're
hiring for an Integrations uh analyst
this is an entry level position for
someone with our experience
um you'll be involved in uh helping to
onboard new securitization to our
platform this is a role that will give
you a lot of opportunity to learn how to
use r as well as other languages like
Python and potentially Scala and you'll
get a lot of exposure to the fixed
income markets
and have you posted it at the Amway hack
our slack I sure will there you go so if
you're coming in Virtual land or even in
person and my hack are slack you can
find the jobs in there in the job
posting channel right so and if you're
virtually and you want to hire someone
but you're not here go to the NY hack
our Slack you can find the link at my
hacker.org in the top right there's a
little slack icon click that you can
post a job all right
cool all right so last chance for jobs
all right cool so
as our regulars remember when we're
doing this every single month for like
over 10 years we didn't start this thing
ever at the beginning but it's been over
10 years we always pick a different
pizza place
this month's Pizza is from Harry's
Italian
I'll put over here so people at home can
see it
they specialize in their Square slices
though they're really rectangular
everyone calls them Squares right but
they especially in square slices now
this has great cheese locks it's been
sitting around a while so everyone who's
in here in person tasting this pizza go
to bit.ly Pizza pull
bitly slash Pizza pole and go on there
and rate the pizza on a scale of never
again poor average good excellent yeah
yeah go take out your smartphones I know
you all have them and check it out and
rate the pizza I see Paul's already
doing it thank you Paul
Paul's always on top of that and let us
know how the pizza is those of you
coming to us virtually let us know in
slack or in the YouTube chat anywhere
what are you eating right now are you
eating pizza eating pierogies eating
pasta eating anything so let us know and
I'm very proud to say that we're serving
pizza here in the only city where you
don't need to qualify what type of pizza
it is
so let us know where let us know what
you're getting
I mentioned it briefly but there's a
wealth of information at nyhackgar.org
you want to see 14 years of previous
talks we have slideshows we have videos
you want to see job postings there's so
much great information in myhackcard.org
check it out
I do want to say thank you to two Sigma
for hosting us it's always great to have
a space like this so thank you very much
if we have an internal Round of Applause
for all the two stigma people
and thank you to everyone involved with
all the tech and everything it's been a
really great experience being here we're
getting used to being back in person all
the technology that goes with it
few other things coming up soon we have
the New York R conference coming up July
11th through 14th there's an event we've
been doing I think for the ninth year
now it grew organically out of this
Meetup until like a two-day party that's
like a four day R party we have two days
of workshops and two days of talks it's
gonna be really great time we have
speakers like Max Kuhn and Rob Hyman
Molly Hui and Asma Tumi it's gonna be a
really great time go to rstats.ai nyr to
learn more about that and since you're a
member of this Meetup you get a 20
discount simply by using code NY hack r
that applies for people in the room that
applies for people virtually
all right and after the talk before the
Q a we're going to give away a couple
tickets to nyr we'll give away a ticket
to someone in the room and we'll give
away a ticket to someone who is tending
who is attending virtually so we're very
happy to give you all those tickets and
anyone else doesn't get a ticket and my
hack R gives you a 20 discount code
we also have a conference we're putting
on down in Tampa on August 23rd to 25th
called d4con you can get more
information at d4con.io the theme there
is different it's not about R explicitly
it's about the sort of the fusion of
like sports entertainment and security
so a nice blend of things so learn more
d4con.io and use code NY hack R for our
20 discount August 23rd through 25th
and the last conference I'll talk about
right now we have our gov that's back
just like nyr but for the government
that is at Georgetown Washington DC
October 18th to 20th it's not officially
on sale yet we haven't announced the
speakers yet but we will soon and again
our stats.ai gov same discount code and
my hack r
we also have the next two months planned
for the Meetup they will be both in
person and virtual we are very excited
to have it both ways June 6 for the next
one and we have showbik bharari talking
about the politics of U.S elections that
should be a really cool talk June 6 will
announce it next week
we also have July planned for the week
before nyr July 6. we have a talk we
have the venue book we're just waiting
to finalize details for the speaker that
will be announced probably June 7th all
right
now anyone out there in person or
virtual who is who wants to give a talk
say hi find me in person find me on
slack on Twitter on LinkedIn find me
anywhere or find Nicole or anyone who
works at Lander analytics or is a member
of the community and knows me say hi and
you can give a talk if you don't I will
volunteer people and I already have some
people in this room I'm already going to
volunteer no one you ever do just saying
it's been a year all right I'll
volunteer other people so we need
speakers to come give a talk
likewise we need hosts we're very
thankful to Sigma or thank you for our
host but we want to make sure we have a
stable host because not every place can
host us every month so if you want to
host us let us know if you have an
office of space for a good amount of
people let us know we'd love to uh take
up in your hospitality
so remember folks check out all the
conferences at nrstaths.ai d4con.io
check out the NY hack our website and my
hackard.org and stick around to get free
tickets and stick around if you're in
person to go to the bar or if you're
virtual do your home bar
all right with that I am very excited to
announce our next speaker who does come
from a city where you have to qualify
the pizza
I want to make that very clear they
don't have pizza there they have Chicago
Pizza I wanna I wanna stress that I
can't stress that enough
and he's a long time friend of the
Meetup he's spoken at the Meetup and
he's spoken at a conference and you may
know him from such packages as
XTS and quantmod not to be confused with
Sybil or tidy Quant right these are
packages that use base R and does really
high performance stuff with a sound API
you can always count on always being the
same it's been the same for 10 years
probably 20 years 20. yeah it's a long
time and you can always get this
consistency which I actually really
appreciate
um so please welcome the great Jeff
[Applause]
Chicago Pizza it's New York style pizza
which probably means something else
um
thank you very much for uh having me I
may have been one of the ones that he
volunteered to come
uh I my talk today is something I kind
of harp on a lot
um amongst colleagues and just kind of
being around data and
I guess high performance Computing for a
long time or seemingly long time my kids
would say it's a long time
and I think my take is I I kind of have
this like aversion to databases
um not because I don't like databases
actually I find them totally fantastic
and intriguing but I also find them to
be Overkill in a lot of situations so my
my general first thing to do is to try
and avoid them so I don't have to
install them or maintain them or all the
other pieces or ask somebody because I
my
very painful memories of database
administrators
not being happy with me so anything I
can do to avoid a database is kind of
somewhere in my head and some of the
software as Jared had mentioned like XTS
does a lot of what a database does
without being a database so a ton of the
premise of the talk I will see if I can
manage not my laptop here and
I'll also
apologize somewhat in advance because I
these are kind of a compendium of
multiple talks I've given
um and I've determined I try to rewrite
talks I literally do rewrite talks it's
probably like that 50th talk I've given
publicly and I intentionally rewrite
them all of the time so they're not the
same
it turns out some of the pieces though I
I don't think I can make any better in
my head so some of the stuff might not
be the same format apologies and events
so I could say databasing without the
database uh you can do a lot without
actually using a formal database and I
kind of think all the cool people do
this
my uh my daughter is uh she said this to
me one day which really was disturbing
but also true
um that yeah the nothing dorkier than
computer people who think they're cool
uh so and I I agree maybe but so
Jared points out I have been writing
open source stuff since kind of that I
don't know the dawn of popular open
source maybe uh is mostly due to R
I started I actually started using
python way before R but are as uh stats
based at the time seemed like a better
option for me
yeah it's not not the year I was born
um just in case you probably figured
that out
I mostly have concentrated in the
finance domain so I wrote kuama back in
06 and XTS was kind of an outgrowth of
qualmad which is time series which I I
assume a lot of you know West but West
built
pandas time series based on XDS so
could have been around a long time uh
which is so tiring to say
also wrote the like interaction
interactive brokers interface for R and
M map which map is closer to what I'm
talking about today I keep looking at
the wrong screen
um
I created
this RN Finance conference which is
happening next week in Chicago we have
held it for this will be the 15th year
minus the year or so we didn't show up
but um 15 years about 300 people I think
it's a Big Mo like some template for uh
Jared's conference yes so um we've been
around for a long time it's been a blast
uh I anybody who likes Finance maybe
everyone in this room uh should come one
year it's a it's a great conference and
it's great for many reasons but it's the
the people that show up are just
fantastic I don't know if that's our
people or I mean we get everyone across
the board half of almost all of our
Keynotes to have no idea what R even is
but they all write code in some language
and like it's just this awesome
community of people that care about
stats and and finance
I currently work and it previously
worked in the quantitative hedge fund
space
um and I live in Chicago though I was
born out here not New York but
Pennsylvania
and I I really might like wheelhouse is
I just love making
things faster than anyone else so this
is where Wes and I maybe maybe disagreed
because uh Wes tried to beat me
but uh I don't think he did though but
the first thing
um well yeah the whole point of this
talk is that I'm gonna look up there is
that uh
a lot of people when they start to think
about using data they think about like
I've got to put it in a database and um
so there's like a billion choices right
it's like postgres sqlite
Oracle if you were crazy vertica all the
billion there's like I think there's
something there's a DB engines website
that ranks databases and uh I think they
have like 410 or something on the list
like which kind of gives you some
indication that none of them ever get it
exactly right right there's just a lot
of different options and I use I mean
I've used probably a lot of them
um I want to say like avoid the urge
and uh because that's that's me I always
tell people they're just files like
almost always they're just files or it's
memory but all the stuff on top does
some extra stuff but it's not it's
definitely not helping performance
so if you have a domain problem you can
usually solve it without the above
so uh I guess the talk the Cadence of
the talk if you will is um oh actually
I'm going to try and I'm also not going
to try and hold up anybody in terms of
going to have a beer or pizza so I'll
I'll try and be
quicker than not
so why do we use databases really as
kind of the first point
what is a database in case anybody
doesn't have like a reasonable grasp on
what's really going on behind the the
curtain or in the black box
and then the core of this is this like
can we get database power without
relying on a database
and in that context this like no DB
which I think somebody else technically
claims that they've used this term no DB
but I can prove that I used it before
anybody else
um like way too long ago but it's the
idea is like kind of I don't hate
databases but like there's so much you
can do without them and if you just know
a couple of basic building blocks
in this case I'm going to talk about
some examples which would be M map which
is kind of the core of things which is
core of most databases actually
um not without argument
and then I have an example a small
example this is not my not my specialty
but a small example of using mmap and
building something that applies to your
domain
and then the last part is uh this
indexing package that I built
which is not on crayon but it's in it's
on GitHub it's been around for a long
time and I built it for again a problem
in my head
so
um
for those
I guess the highest level I could think
of of what a database is it's basically
just a bunch of Records generally some
way to look stuff up so whether they're
like it's going to be fast to look it up
or not there's just a place where you
put your data and then you go and fetch
it which is why most people say I need a
database but you probably don't
this is a very crude although colorful
version of a database and the the notion
is like if you can kind of think about
how a database looks to you or me in
like physical space or whatever not
physical but virtual space if you will
and then um and then how it actually is
laid out and there's kind of two there's
a bunch of different types of databases
but there's in like tabular world
there's a couple different versions
there's like row oriented and column
oriented
Fortran and R use generally like kind of
a column representation and I don't I
think numpy allows you to do both if I
remember I don't know what the default
default is but um
but in general you can see like if I had
a bunch of rows
and I want to store them because you got
to turn them into something flat at some
point right they're going to be written
out somewhere they they have to live
either next to each other or somehow
adjacent to each other or I guess it's
the same but um and in a row database
they're literally just like across so it
means you can really get like if you
just need to pull out a row it's very
easy to go to that you know that that
chunk of memory that's there and go grab
it and then send it back and do whatever
you want for each one of the rows
column ones work a little differently in
that they're organized column major so
you get you know all the a b z x and B
uh together and then the next and
actually I screwed up the ordering down
below
um either way they're next to each other
in column space
indexes which are really the thing that
drives databases and the thing that
makes them seemingly fast and magical is
really just some I mean it could be
different things but here you could
easily process you know approximate most
of them with a simple sort of whatever
column you're looking things up on not
at the core and I guess my point is like
there's no magic there's no it's sad
it's super sad to me but there's no
magic in anything
um So eventually you kind of look around
enough and dig into details and you
realize there's there's just no magic uh
I don't know if anybody's how many
people have had malort anybody anybody
I was gonna bring a bottle too but uh
could not find it at the airport and
they usually sell at the airport but the
Lord is anybody comes to Chicago I will
buy you a malort 100
what's that is that a threat is it sorry
oh a threat uh this could be yeah um
it's it's a
yeah I don't it doesn't even have a
description it's my Lord look it up um
it's uh it's a drink but it is
it's not a pleasant drink if you will
um but it's it's uh
I don't know it grows on you I don't
drink it very often but I definitely
drink it when people come to town
topic oh yeah I guess that the other
thing is that deep dish pizza that's
that's a real Pizza
uh databases as I said there's obviously
a bunch of different types of databases
the the thing I just drew was
not a particularly fancy database and
it's kind of the one but it's the one
thing like most versions of data are
tabular almost everything you get is
tabular or it's just a bunch of stuff or
like documents or something but there's
a whole bunch of different ways people
organize databases which also means that
there's the 400 plus databases that
exist in the world at any given time
um key values and documents and time
series and geospatial I I'm partial to
the time series stuff there's these
Vector like embeddings kind of databases
now there's graph databases object
stores like S3 there's just a bunch of
ways to hold on to data and again it's
like you had a record and you need to
get to it and bring it back or put it
there
but at its core like kind of all they're
doing that's all I care about what
they're doing like I don't really care
what they're doing technically inside
maybe I do but like I don't really care
at the end of the day I have a problem I
need to solve it I need to solve fast I
need to not run out of memory all of
those things and and maybe also for
cheap so like those things matter to me
so record some way to get to it
um
the thing is most of these databases
they're they're really the same as the
languages certain things they all have
some structure some
some memory outline or yeah memory
organization or like a data structure
that's holding on to your data whether
it's like a csv-ish thing or like a
bunch of different ways like documents
or whatnot in R and again I I apologize
that not everyone in the room
maybe even likes are but um I'm gonna
keep talking about R and I've used
Python and I like go actually and I even
like python but I don't like python for
statistics but I do like python in
general except for the mutability if
somebody here could explain to me the
mutability of Python and the and the
Damage that does and make sense to me
that would be great I will buy you a
case of malort
yeah that was less of a threat
um but uh so in R we have things like
lists or data frames and absolutely
pandas made data frames available in
python or environments
um
they're they're pretty much databases
right they do everything a database does
uh with the exception of things like if
it's too big they don't they don't
really fit unless you have a giant
machine
um but even if you have a giant machine
usually there's other things on that
machine or you are running other things
on that machine even if there's not
other things on the machine so like
database is good because
to get rid of some of the problems like
that memory and also fast search in
standard uh
structures you you won't necessarily
have like a lookup design that would
make it fast for you more efficient
so the two caveats or the two things I
need out of a database if you will is
allow them to live outside of memory
because they don't always have as much
memory as possible or I want I guess I
never have as much memory as I want and
then make searches
search Fast right and not not just to
like
the the benchmarks everyone sees
benchmarks and benchmarks are fun but
benchmarks are generally useless
in my experience like they're always
maybe not always but a lot of them are
contrived in some cases and they're
never exactly your problem and I don't
know they it concerns me because then I
go and have to iterate over which
database does this part better and not
this part better and so I usually have
like one problem I want to solve and
it'll be like great if I could just
solve that one problem in the way I
needed to so to run and also use use
maybe everyone here likes SQL not a big
fan of sequel
um I like to use like I like to use r or
I like to write code and in those
contexts I don't want to have one extra
layer of some something that lets me get
data back into the language I need to
use it in so I kind of want to minimize
that gap between me using the data and
fetching the data
so again on the outside of memory
brilliantly there's this m map which is
a system call uh it exists basically a
map or map view of file in Windows but
exists everywhere and it basically just
lets the operating system take over for
taking stuff from disk and bringing it
into your process
again there's a lot of hand wavy here
physical and whatever be literal but the
that the fast part is like I said before
it's
you just need an index of some sort and
there's a bunch of different ways to do
this but it's not super hard you can
make it you can make a kind of junky one
and it'll be better than you could
imagine
if for those so who again I like
technical audiences because everyone's
super smart but uh who uses or kind of
have played around low level mmap calls
anybody thumbs up one two couple people
very few people and that was a weird one
because like it literally drives almost
everything in databases and on your on
your machines but it's all behind the
scenes and and it's also really hard to
find documentation for because most of
the people who know it are like low
level OS people or database people or
file system people not not me basically
um although now I know more but uh it
it's really neat it's only like two
functions
and you basically memory map a file or
some set of memory and sorry some sort
of like a disk something that lives on
disk maybe there's different ways to do
this but like a file and you bring it in
and you don't actually bring it in at
all you just tell the OS that like I
want the bytes at the beginning of the
file
and to some part of the file or maybe
offset somewhere in the file and keep
them ready for me to use so it doesn't
doesn't have to read the file directly
it doesn't do anything right away and
then you have this offset to go get the
pieces the bytes but it's just the bytes
so it's not super duper helpful and then
the one way to release them let the OS
take them back effectively or that
mapping back and it's it is virtual
memories when you run out of real memory
it kind of goes to this paging thing and
Os handles it all
but you can actually manage it yourself
the uh
so like I say it's used kind of
everywhere it's binary which is not
super useful if you're used to using
types or things in like a regular
language but it's there it's also
cross-platform so you can kind of use it
for in you know as inter-process
communication between whatever you're
running I have that go code or I've got
R code or I've got python code that's
generating something that my R code
needs all that stuff I can kind of share
using kind of the common underlying like
doubles or whatever yeah whatever you
want to phrase them as like you know
four byte ends or something
so this is also something you could
change the date on there all the time
um because it's you always think you
have a lot more memory than you used to
and it's true
but
like I said that is true but uh if you
look at machines they have well they
have a lot more memory they also have a
lot more processing cores and when you
start to like average them out you
really don't have that much more memory
per sort of unit of compute which is
really the limiting factor to me like I
can't make
I don't know 100 jobs running at the
same time if I only have uh you know a
fraction of whatever a quarter of a
terabyte of ram as you start to have
just not very much memory left per
process so it's good to be able to share
this memory so again if you skip that
and do like a database which sounds
magical and is offloaded to somebody
else usually a DBA
and more Hardware
that you can't really hit a database
with a lot of connections some you can
but a lot of them don't like it your
dbas totally don't like it so
those are problems Network also doesn't
like it when you're moving things back
and forth serialization not super good
either all these things are like real
costs that belong to a database which
solves a different problem but it
doesn't sound like my analytics problem
I guess I should have phrased all of
this around like analysis instead of
storing like my bank account data sure
that should be in a database because it
needs to be somewhere but um
the like going and getting data to work
on I don't really want all that overhead
I just don't need that overhead and it
turns out you really don't need it and
even better is now instead of waiting
for a Spinning Disk to go you can you
know ssds are brilliantly fast M2 level
stuff optane stuff which has been sort
of discontinued at this point but
blindingly fast and
and Orders of magnitude cheaper than uh
RAM so like all of a sudden you kind of
have terabytes of pretty fast storage
maybe not fail to cash or uh RAM fast
cash but like pretty pretty fast
um faster than enough more or less
depending on your problem
so again oh that's weird
um
this is like you say using disk so you
kind of have an infinite amount of
memory available if you will
this is this is the m map package that I
wrote although this just happens to be
the syntax the syntax I wrote is
actually very uh low level so it kind of
looks more or less the same as you would
if you see your python or something
except for the r version handles the
the translation
to the types in R so again there's
multiple types but you can see like here
I generate whatever three billion
floating Point numbers and then write
them out to disk so it's whatever like
23 or 22 or whatever gigabytes of data
or just a single Vector floats random
floats nonetheless and you write them
out and then I can read them back in
by a map and it takes no time because
I'm not actually reading them in they're
just they're now available to me the
whole whatever it was three billion
doubles
you can sort of see in the syntax in the
r version you can see it says you know
there's three billion of them whatever
it shows you a handful you can get
access to any of them and all of those
things there's no timings around them
but they're basically instantaneous they
are instantaneous and you can see it
doesn't take up any memory sorry if
you're not used to our like that
the bottom V cells thing kind of from
the top is the thing that's consuming
your local memory no memory is being
harmed here I guess that's where I would
refer the phrase that
um
so I could say 20-ish something
gigabytes of data
you use no memory
in your system again now if you're
obviously going through it you're using
time and memory but like you don't need
to load it all at the same time uh in
and map is pretty neat it's at least R
in that package because you can it works
on OS 10 it works on Windows it works on
Linux it works on anything
stable since 2010 it's been checked for
I don't know how many millions of times
on crayon but uh on the our archive page
I also built a whole bunch of things to
like support basically any way you could
represent data inside of
memory is built into it
so but the point is not to use it
directly it's to build upon it
and sorry I guess
yeah here's some of the types it can
handle so like anything you might have
already this is actually kind of the
core is that I I really want to operate
on binary data from somewhere else so I
don't like it's sort of silly to
generate data write it out and then read
it back in that's not very useful but
like if I have a process that's
generating I don't know any of these you
know like somehow four bytes uh floating
point
I I need to be able to read that in so
this thing will support all the
conversions kind of magically or
unfortunately does not have all of those
directly so it does some internal work
to make it work but you can kind of read
in anything also write out anything if
you need to with a note that you'll lose
Precision on certain things a quick
little example
of uh how this does work or and yeah how
it works not really internally but kind
of how it works so you can see you just
map Things read them back in map them
read them back in you get the
how big the thing is you can get the
individual numbers there's very very
silly examples but it's super simple it
doesn't require any skill it just kind
of says like go get me this file read it
in lazily and give me the piece of
information I need on it
um
in the one thing that's extra useful
is that there are like a if you go back
to or if I went back to my
this thing so like the row format
they're all stuck together like a
c-struct so it's like there's an element
inside of your piece of data that might
be two bytes wide and then four bytes
wide and then I don't know 20 bytes wide
and then four bytes wide and they're all
representing different things it might
be a string you might be uh integer it
might be whatever in that same way data
again that you're reading from some
other process
you can tell it what that what that
process or what that data looks like and
say oh there's it four byte or whatever
16 you know short integer there's a
normal four byte integer there's a
regular floating point in there
it kind of puts them together and then
you can read and write them so
everything like in that struct like row
based orientation is there
that
sort of structure is then
as an example
I wish I knew where I was here but um as
an example is there's this uh our Cosmo
package in our which is I think
currently experiencing a uh not on
crayon moments because of some Upstream
dependency which is not a map broke it
but um it is used for the for I know
nothing about this field by the way but
like
microwave radiation there or whatever
waves that they capture to
whatever
plot stuff I really don't know anything
about this field but you can see like
the previous example or the previous way
you could do this in r
you would have to load the entire data
set and it took whatever that a long
time right 900 seconds
and now it takes basically no time it's
like 400 times faster so they can now
iterate through all of what they're
doing on the research side without
having to either run out of memory or
run out of time to compute it and it
lets them very simply kind of iterate
over what they're working on
to do that now
for anything that kind of made it
like what if you could just do it for a
basic data frame like get rid of the
data frame in memory put it into this
mem map file and load it
again tried to make it super simple same
kind of thing you say as mmap it
magically it's not really much magic
actually but it takes your this Mt cars
data set which is what you see there
and transforms it into out of memory so
like or sorry not in memory using this
c-struct thing so you can see at the
bottom like a it renders the same in R
plus or minus um to see everything and
then there's also uh you can see it's
you know even it's a silly small data
set so it doesn't really make much
difference but you can see it doesn't
take up any memory once you're using the
memory mapped version of it but it also
means you can share it amongst processes
so if you pretended it wasn't a dumb
data set and it was something large you
don't need to consume memory across all
the processes they can actually all
share them on the same machine
um this is another sort of example a
little bit
um sorry this is actually taking a map
and extending it to like more of a
problem space or another domain
um this is another this is like another
entity I am involved in and uh we kind
of monitor all the regulatory Holdings
that the SEC records and so in the
particular case of like 13f filings
which are just institutional Holdings
it's like you guys obviously file them
as well but um there's some things
probably even more than this now maybe
60 or 70 million Holdings are recorded
there and it's they're all separate
they're all like across 200 000 files
and such it's kind of a mess
um it's not a total mess but it's not
super easy to deal with but you can also
take it
kind of work it in and hide a lot of the
like how you make it this way but you
can take it and put it into this
indexing package that I wrote
to make it look like a database I mean
it looks just like a database except for
if you use R it looks a lot more like R
than writing SQL so I can say give me
IBM for this reporting period across
whomever and then give me back on that
right side that transform sort of Select
thing
um exactly like regular articles I just
want to you know whatever multiply by a
thousand because everything's
filed that way and then per share you
know implied price kind of thing and I
don't know where the filers the ik comes
from but basically you can run like a
SQL query
but without being sequel against
a very you know not giant large but like
70 million 60 million or whatever this
one is 57 million um 14 gig data set
without using again my no Ram harmed
you're using no memory right so it's
it's just there you're not actually
consuming any memory so any computation
you need to do on your side doesn't need
this sort of sift or exchange out the
data you needed to bring in to go and
grab the particular component you needed
and it's also super fast right
whatever 70 milliseconds not
not really slow probably on par with
most databases they would have that
level and this might be from a few years
back frankly
um but uh
it's pretty fast and it doesn't require
any code really it's like I showed
before it's a couple of those little
functions that you wrap and then
everything magically happens in the
background and it's all in your own
process so there's no database you're
not running anything you don't have a
postgres running somewhere or piping
things to postgres or making sure it's
standing or all those things like it's
just static data that anybody can run
anywhere
um this is sorry if you know there's a
sort of a structural break in the in the
style of these slides I couldn't quite
make this description
as good as my previous one so I kind of
stitched together two of these things
um and this is what like this
combination of M map and indexing and
the whole point is like indexing I like
and it's super useful but it's the fact
that you can build upon really basic
pieces like and map and sorting a vector
and you can turn kind of anything if
it's an r or wherever very easily it's
something that's high performance that
is like enables you to do either more
research or get something faster into
production or whatever but like just
really really simple building blocks so
here this indexing thing is uh like I
say pretty fast search I feel like I
lost something on this page
um
and
what indexing does is really it's like a
column store like a vertica or
Fortran or r at their core
and it adds binary search also some like
bitmap indexing kind of magically and
then in this end map so you don't need
to keep it in memory
same thing it's uh we're basically
taking a data frame which you could do
in python or whatever and write out each
one of those columns
into a vial again Arrow kind of does a
lot of this too but um
but again with an additional step
this then allows you to have unlimited
data and more importantly to me is you
get to keep the r interface like there's
no difference in how I consume the data
from my like our perspective our code
perspective and really there's just
three pieces to this whole package it's
you create an index you load the index
you already created and then there's
like the subset operator
um you see it kind of does a bunch of
different things maybe different things
to make it faster
kind of looks like a database but it's
all in memory it's all in their own
process there's nothing else running but
it's just as fast as the database in
fact Benchmark this way back before
Amazon
bought Parks out which is now redshift
and the only public Benchmark this beat
Park sell on
um and that was like a long time ago
with really
not great code on my side
there's not a lot of it's kind of the
way like kdb works too there's not
the beauty is in its Simplicity and how
you can get a lot of performance out of
very simple things
um and in this case I could say this
this is probably the best way I can
describe it is that this what indexing
does it lets you kind of build this
environment or a data frame effectively
of a bunch of columns and then you can
tell which column you want to search on
same thing there are this is like
internally but not really relevant other
than you can see it does extra stuff but
not super important to user space
you can see super easy to create things
syntax on the right is a little bit
more novel or useful I can say like give
me everything less than zero or
everything greater than one and less
than minus yeah I guess that's a one
um minus three or even transform the
output and all in pure r no extra weird
I say weird but no extra SQL or anything
else
and as possible and probably somewhere
near the end of my slides
um this was again a pretty old data set
now but
something like a bunch of us Equity
options contracts like daily contracts
and not huge by any stretch but way
bigger than my laptop which plugs into
the back of the room at the time
um it doesn't fit doesn't work you could
not do anything with it so here though
by mapping them all in you can now get
from 70 million ish
Rose I can grab everything that belongs
to Apple or I can and you can see like
you know 91 000 things show up
um in you know milliseconds
so again not not really big but my
little MacBook was
uh not up to the task of it keeping it
in memory especially if anything else is
running
this is sort of a little more of a
demonstration if you will
um a whole bunch of
queries you would maybe run to explore
an options data set
or kind of generate some new data set
from it and you know they're they're
pretty reasonably complicated queries
they're not they're not anything
tremendous
but they're I don't know they'd be
they'd be painful to write in in all
honesty in SQL for me
but I can kind of do anything right I
could say like all the standard stuff
you'd kind of expect to think about and
be able to quickly see and you can run
them all in and it's like this seven
card seven graphs which are not super
fast to draw in five seconds on again on
a MacBook Air that has no memory and is
running you know against a pretty large
data set compared to what it what it has
resource-wise
and those are all things that get
generated again useless to any of us in
the room but nonetheless like visually
kind of instantaneously you can get this
view of your data that does not fit in
your computer whatever again you could
have it you could have a thousand nodes
and
still run into the limit that you've
also got 200 people using the nodes and
you've got to be scheduled and you've
just got to make the best use of your
resources and this thing can pull off
most of what you want to do without kind
of any resources except for a little bit
of code so
that's kind of my take I feel like this
might be the end of my slides
um yeah and uh so
you can do a lot without
relying on other people's code I guess
is number one
um it doesn't really require much it you
I mean I have code to do this but it's
really just a system call that every
machine has and you could look at my
code and figure out trivially how you
would access the system call and build
whatever you need and I'm sure
I would guess Python and Julia have
something similar I don't think it's
quite as well
um
I don't think it's quite as easy to use
but it would be trivial to do
um and you can get so much like you can
still need you still need a database I
don't want to Discount the database but
like for regular analytical processing
of lots of data you can do a lot more
with less resources which I am always
resource constrained and for basically
free and it'll never break to like you
know the database isn't down somebody's
not yelling at you at three in the
morning you can kind of get by with a
lot less and get the same output or
better
just by knowing a few of the little
tools underneath and how they work
so if anybody has you can go to the
GitHub the actual those packages are
there all the source codes there
um and then uh I don't know that
LinkedIn is whatever I don't really like
LinkedIn but it's there do you want that
um and then in the last in my email my
emails everywhere and they're all
different emails but that that one
actually belongs to a
time series database which I know right
now that I'm actually building
um she talked about maybe last time but
uh yeah so anyway that's it I am happy
to take any
questions or asks or criticisms or tell
you where the pizza is again or whatever
cool thank you very much
necessarily oh
um are you embracing the type now is
that what that means uh it was mostly to
mock the Tidy verse pipe yeah I hate I
hate no I like pipes but not
I don't use pipes very often in R but
when I do I would use that one and then
the other right hand side
uh maybe I don't know like I say I don't
use them I use them in in Shell
scripting because that's really good but
uh yeah all right so me strong
questions
I remember please repeat the question
yep
does
indexing require that you have a data
frame like set of columnar
and map tables or can use indexing if
you've done
like some weird like row based you know
more complex than that so uh it's a good
question
um sorry yes Ken yes okay I'll try and
repeat it hold on let's give it a
challenge
um does indexing the package
require
a data frame structure to do its
indexing on is that correct yeah yeah
okay
um I think that is true the the thing
that indexing does they're not it looks
like they're row based because that's
sort of the way they're represented in a
data frame but the way R represents them
is polymer so what actually happens
behind the scenes is they each one of
the columns is written out separately to
its own file and then can be lazily
loaded if you will via a map
based on what subset you're looking for
but also to that point they're indexed
by
column so even if like they're you know
what I mean like they're they're row
oriented if you will when they come back
but they are actually being pulled from
like a column or database
foreign
okay uh so the simpler question then is
can I run indexing on
mapped
vectors that I have on disk that I'm not
creating out of R but you know if I have
like a bunch of long binary vectors that
I'm mapping from some other data source
will can indexing work with those or
does it have to be created out of the
indexing
data frames
uh so the question is does it need to
originate in R yeah more or less
um it doesn't really I mean
it probably does only by construction
not by any real requirement like the
indexing part would just need to know
where the data lives basically what
happens is at the beginning everything
is just written out binary
so like whatever it is you've got a
floating point you've got a string
you've got a whatever or set of strings
and they're all written out in column or
fashion so in and I say columnar they're
all written out one by one as a file
binary file with some predetermined link
the number of things in it and so forth
they also do all have to have the same
number of items because they need to
line up but
apart from that the the indexing part
will use that to then generate
the index if you will so it doesn't it
doesn't need it ahead of time but it
needs to at least know what it is so if
I have four billion lengths
and map binary things yep indexing will
do the build the index code and all of
that although I don't know how fast it
will be but yes yeah it's not super
optimized at this moment although it
does work on large scale stuff
um but no it would not have any
you wouldn't even need any extra
coercion if you will it would just kind
of go at it as data's over here turn it
into an index and in the indexing that
it does is
uh everything from and again it's it's
mostly a an effort to Showcase like what
you can do with the underlying tools and
how kind of easy it is to build the
indexing package by way of like the the
mmat packages
I don't know 20 I don't know actually
maybe 20 000 lines of C code it's all
like super highly optimized C code and
for all the different data types and
everything the indexing package that
sits on top of it or uses it is
maybe a couple thousand lines tops of
our code it's very it's super trivial
it's like basically it just takes the
pieces underneath and then puts them
together in this data frame format but
just like that our Cosmo package they do
the same thing with
M map underneath and I don't know if
they built an index on top of it but
they basically have I actually had to
change the they have weird like the fits
data structure which is like some
astronomy Centric
structure for managing all that stuff it
is uh
they use big ND in somewhere in the
struct like there's something kind of
wonky about it because it dates from I
don't know it's like 30 years old or 40
years old and um so they still use big
Indians right I kind of modified this
damn map stuff to be able to handle big
Indian within instruct so like if you
could think of you know it's got a
regular internet for some reason there's
a few big Indian it can handle all of
that kind of back and forth so but they
just took the regular mmap code there's
another there's like a gene sequencing
package that does the same thing well
not the same thing but like similar-ish
stuff where it takes like this
underlying binary that I have no idea
and map doesn't have any idea about and
is able to like kind of stitch it
together in a way that makes sense like
whether taking the headers into a
separate section and like understanding
that breakdown
to index that
I don't you wouldn't like directly work
it could easily work or you're just like
that hack it effectively because it's
not doing anything it's just taking a
vector turning into something like an
rle like a run length encoding or some
bitmap vector or whatever would make
sense
um and or it also makes sense sometimes
to just not have an index like right
depending on what you're looking at it
like especially like running coding kind
of stuff depending on cardinality and
such you might just be better off
scanning the whole thing or like where
you're at so it lets you do a lot of
those things but by default indexing is
kind of dumb out of the box if you've
ever used like data table in R it's
basically like an out or kdb it's
basically like what those two things can
do but where they're kind of prescribed
like a data table in R is
it's just rectangular there's no there's
no multi-dimensional anything it's
rectangular so it does the same kind of
thing except for data table in our
has to be in memory and when you run out
of memory you're kind of screwed so like
this allows you to jump past that and
also not have to use up any of your
memory for a data set that you might
only be using a part of
thanks thanks
before we ask another question I was
reminded I was supposed to do the
giveaways first then we'll do the rest
of the questions so be right back with
you of all your questions uh so pause
for one second and I'll do what I should
have done five minutes ago
all right uh we're gonna give away two
tickets
um and we also have a virtual question
also
um all right so two tickets one for
virtual nyr one for in person nyr the
virtual winner and you'll be contacted
is Helen passio Helen virtual land
somewhere we'll be contacting you for
your free ticket
and then in person do you have to be
physically present to claim it is that
the rule all right if you're not here
we're moving on uh
um Aaron amankwa Aaron all right you win
a ticket
[Applause]
we'll find you afterwards and get your
information cool all right then I'll ask
the virtual question since I'm up here
um how do we get existing data like in a
CSV memory mapped
uh that one I actually did re so I
this package dates from the indexing
package the map package I've updated all
the time so I
like many of you in the room I work in a
reasonably guarded space and they didn't
let me touch anything for the most part
um but I did maintain this package it's
that map thing because it has nothing to
do with Finance for uh all the time I
was not allowed to do anything else and
so that one's continuously updated it
doesn't need a lot of updating the
indexing one though uh I has always
worked but I've not updated very much
except for in the last like six months I
started to make it more kind of feature
filled and more documentation and kind
of readying it to publish
and in that context there is now a m map
CSV function that allows you to sort of
like blanket create actually as a map
will create the CSV but then you can
also read in a CSV directly with that
he does a little bit of gymnastics to
kind of read each column first and then
write them out but it does like if you
had 100 columns it's only going to read
one at a time so you still preserve your
local memory and write them out
again it's not the indexing package also
is like multi-threaded and it does a
bunch of kind of fancier stuff it also
even does I didn't point this out but it
does um
like horizontal and vertical kind of by
default it does vertical partitioning
but like does horizontal partitioning so
you can run it across different
um different either files or file
systems or yeah it does a lot of that
stuff tries tries really hard to be a
database without being a database but
yeah there's now a function that just
says like create CSV or read CSV so it's
navigate to M map CSV so it doesn't
collide with read CSV
and it does multiple csvs like I said
except you pointed to a bunch of files
and sort of creating those needs uh yeah
although they don't have to be the same
length to glue them together
because then they wouldn't make sense
a number of rows columns it doesn't care
about it doesn't even care about the
order of the columns kind of like a
database like I mean they might be you
know they're somewhere it doesn't really
matter it shouldn't matter to you it'll
preserve the order you loaded them in
but that's just for your own benefits of
like seeing them in the same order
instead of all shifting around but
they're it doesn't it doesn't care
inside
not particularly oh sorry can you can
you uh like have primary secondary Keys
across multiple tables effectively like
can you can you join tables
yeah uh not yeah not by default
certainly but I it'd be fun to add I
like you say I'm sure it's it was kind
of this proof of concept that turned out
to be really useful and I'm trying to
make it into something that's more
useful to other people so yeah any I
mean any if you send me an email or I
mean I'll remember that but like things
like that would be neat to add in
um just use cases that I didn't need but
are also useful to other people that's
the whole reason I mean I like open
source so much and I dislike that open
source is kind of in trouble because so
many people have
uh contributed and then kind of lost
interest in contributing because no one
got anything out of it or very you know
little out of it and they kind of are
you know in handful of cases vilified
for contributing things
um I I would like to see open source not
die acting the world needs to not have
it done so yeah any suggestions anything
usage whatever I'm super excited to do
always
thank you
question on just multiple set of
settings for these tables like I guess
the question would be when you subset
the amount um
does it load in each individual column
at the time when you subset or how does
that work no it actually goes so there
there may have been a slide on there
that when you it doesn't like um it
doesn't materialize anything
um what it will do is just find the
pieces it needs and then when you're
ready to materialize it by in the r
syntax it's just like you need a
trailing comma like if you just if you
gave the command without a comma it will
just tell you how many things like
actually one of the examples that how
many times Apple existed that that's
basically instantaneous because it
doesn't have to go lift the data so yeah
does that is that what you were asking
yeah I was guessing it's also just like
if those seem like a subset for example
if I wanted to then type that into
another substance
uh that does actually work although it
needs to be like in I don't remember the
syntax of that but yes it does it tries
hard and again this is where like real
databases
can do a better job because they have
better like um what's the right word uh
planning like query plans um so this
this tries and it also tries to do
things like uh com it handles
compression as well and and does some
other kind of fancy things
a lot of them at the margin don't really
add much value which is weird
um but yeah it also does things like if
you're if you're if you're looking for
like a large sequence it won't memory
map that chunk it'll actually read it
sequentially because it's generally a
lot faster than a memory map memory apps
are good for
Random Access not super good for well
it's just fine I guess same as random
access but it's like sequential pulling
is much much faster so it tries to
condition itself in a sort of simplistic
query plan to say
don't do this yet now do this and make
sure you get it this way instead of this
way so
yep thank you
okay then
um another question from virtual land
I'll pass this compare to FS or Arrow or
big memory or disappear
yeah cool don't you're not might oh my
gosh okay how does this compare to what
was the first one uh FS day memory Arrow
or disarray okay uh I don't I don't
think I know what FS or disk frame is
um although I think I've seen this Frame
at some years ago yeah is that still uh
functioning the person who ran
gotcha yeah um not I mean no no shade on
that because I have a lot of things that
are not touched but um yeah uh big so
the thing that I think M map so indexing
is closer to like big memory or let's
just say big memory
um because they both are kind of tabular
in in nature and map itself is more the
thing that drives or would drive big
memory if it wasn't hard-coded to be
tabular so like mmap lets you do things
like the cosmo data or Gene data or
whatever any arbitrary structure that is
binary in nature like time zone files
for instance time zone like compiled
time zone files have all this crazy
weird offsets and like those are
generally speaking read very slowly by
the operating system even and certainly
by R so you can do things that are much
faster by understanding that the binary
format and you could do it the same with
like whatever audio files or anything
that's that's not strictly you know one
type of thing and it's got some
structure to it and that would let you
build your own like memory mapping
effectively for some structure there's
nothing else that does that like FF is
another one that maybe that I don't know
if that's FS or FF but FF is the other
package that does this and there's like
a billion of these FF ones it's m map is
faster I don't know if they all work on
Windows this works on all operating
systems has for the last 12 years 14
years
um
like I say they're the two things are
like M map is really the it's a very
likely
uh exposed version of the system call so
anything you can pass to the system call
you can pass and whether it works
depends on the operating system you're
on like sometimes those system calls
don't actually exist on the operating
system like reserving space and all the
stuff or shared objects like sometimes
those don't work on Windows or or other
operating systems
um but Mapp tries not to get in the way
it just makes it easy to consume the
output because otherwise it's just raw
bytes and like unless you know it's an
integer even M map doesn't know it's an
integer doesn't have Header information
so you need to know what's underneath it
but once it does it gives you back that
whereas in python or Pearl or anything
else unless you have like a special
package to do it you're just going to
get back raw bytes which is then you
have to do all the work to convert them
back to whatever you wanted and do them
either
this all does this all happens in C so
it's like as fast as possible and it's
all been the coolest part of R is the
packaging system as Jared can attest or
also the most painful part
um is that
then the rigor that that thing has to go
through across things from like old
versions of Solaris for the longest time
on spark it still had to compile and
Loan on spark it was like this is
ridiculous I don't have a spark machine
I did but I don't anymore it's again
it's crazy it still has to but it's
super neat because it still runs on all
of them it's like okay well you kind of
know you push the bound on all of this
stuff and it just kind of works but I
it's harder to do when you're higher
level so this thing I tried to make it
you know as perfect as possible at the
low level so then you can build upon it
without worrying about that going wrong
effectively
I don't know if that answered the
question but
yeah
it's it's different than some uh Mike is
actually the big memory person has um
kind of just even last conference he he
pointed out he's like I think you're the
M map approach he wants to help on that
map because he's like I think that's the
right way to do it because then you
don't have this like oh it doesn't fit
in a table or if you give up other
things though like it's hard to do
matrix multiplication here whereas like
they've kind of solved that but you
could also solve it by like building
upon the low layer so that's where we
talked about like collaborating on
things just because like it's their way
is very restrictive like if you fall
into the pattern similar to the
databases like right if you have a
database like redis is great for what
redis does but it's not super good for
other things and postgres is not good
for rents type stuff or like or
type stuff right even much maligned
Bongos like I still use because I
don't know it's dumb and it works and it
just works like I don't know what to say
but it's like it works and uh so yeah
that's the point was like make a package
or make this tool
make it easier to use the underlying
system calls that everything relies upon
really everything and uh and make it
robust that's kind of the takeaway and
indexing was just like a good example it
made it easier to use for me from
tabular data
and the main key was referring to is
Michael Kane he spoke at the Meetup a
few months ago so you search
nyhacker.org and you can search for
Michael Kane he's given a bunch of talks
most recently a few months ago and big
memory is a out of memory Matrix not a
data frame but a matrix
yeah yeah correct oh that's the other
side too yeah
that's a pretty big difference which is
where like I wrote XTS and XCS is all
it's just a matrix and people have
complained for 17 years this is just the
Matrix because you can't
you can't store a column of whatever
tickers
but it's also you can't multiply a
column of a ticker so it was always
based on a major like it was the order
of operations in R was it's a matrix I
can do Matrix math on it and if it's got
some characters in it I can't I would
never do that so they shouldn't even be
there which is kind of
maybe a ridiculous assumption yeah but
it was like that's what it was meant to
be a replacement in with time for
matrices I was just like so I tried to I
tried to constrain all of them to like
their domain effectively
any another in-person question
all right doesn't mean check all right
either one person one last second I
check what's the person in line there
was a question about loading data from
csvs but sort of answer that right
um there's a question about how does how
do you write the original binary file
but it sounds like you don't need a
binary file csvs
yeah or it'll make it like if you do as
a map it'll create all the files but you
actually that at the core is just read
bin or write bin I mean that sorry the
read bin is less of that but like to
write them out you can't you can't
create a file with a map you're actually
like that system call you need to have
like a prescribed range or a size of the
file to work with even if it's it can
technically be like a whatever empty
file or whatever zero byte file but um
they although that's super
implementation specific uh but for the
most part if you write out a big binary
file it has you know it's got a million
four byte integers it's four million
bytes long
all zeros and then you can map anything
into it
or but I mean MF does this for you if
you just say as M map for a vector of
three billion yes
yep yeah and you can specify where yeah
it basically it reads the Cs so if it
starts from a CSV it'll read the CSV in
uh one column at a time effectively
um
I'm trying to remember how that actually
works but yes it'll read each part in
and then write them out so it can use
the whole thing later without consuming
all of the memory up front if I try to
do a save RDS on this object it won't
work it's an environment that has got
yeah it's basically just pointers to
OS owned memory so yeah you're not going
to save them okay
this is a question for me can I have to
write the square brackets and test these
like uh
I mean yeah it's super like if you look
at the indexing code it's not it's
pretty there's some kind of
crazy stuff in there but for the most
part it's super simple yeah it's
basically just going at the
just getting stuff on them I mean maybe
inside of your crazy
whatever
tidy version of those brackets
um inside they really call brackets so
yeah you can wrap it with whatever you
want
that's correct yeah and lastly
the seven problems
uh that's a good question I don't think
so but I can dig up and put on all right
yep last chance to answer any questions
we're ready to go to your husband
okay then big round of applause to Jeff
[Applause]
the slides and the video will be up at
nyhackgar.org in a few days a big thank
you to Sigma for hosting us here uh yeah
big round of applause for them thank you
some of you worked here but
I remember we have next most Meetup June
6th the Meetup after that July 6th we
have the New York R conference July 11th
through 14th we have d4con come up in
August and our gov in October and we'll
have many meetups and other fun events
um going on
and uh we'll see you next month so thank
you very much everyone for coming see
you soon